i feel like i'm i'm just using i'm
abusing technology just
to make a business uh so like the with
software
think about like software it's uh you
can make copies of it
right and it doesn't cost you anything
[Music]
stephen blum thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders it's been
almost seven years since we worked
together last
through the hacking generation y company
that i ran how are you
so good amazing that was the same
response he gave me seven years ago so
i'm glad that
you know so much has changed you're
being consistent so i just love that
stephen you're the chief technology
officer of pubnub i'm
incredibly excited to learn more about
what you guys are doing
and diving into some of the things that
really make you excited about the
technology you're developing but before
that
i always love starting with the journey
of the entrepreneur
and the journey of the leader because
you have a phenomenal journey you've
worked at quite a few companies
as lead as senior developer and
architecture so tell me a little bit
about what you're
what you're passionate about and and
taking all the way back to your college
days how do you get excited about
technology
to the point where you are now oh wow
yeah uh it's it's it's a lot it's a lot
it's a lot yeah really it's really it's
all about that means to an
end so technology sure it's great
and it can get you to where you want to
go from from what gets me excited
what really excites me is that business
model right i'm
really attracted that this is a way to
like yeah attract you
you don't hear that so much from chief
technology officers right
um yeah that's a that's actually a good
point and uh
i feel like i feel like i'm i'm just
using i'm abusing technology just
to make a business uh so like the with
software
think about like software it's uh you
can make copies of it
right and it doesn't cost you anything
right
i like that idea that means production
costs are pretty dang low
so how can we make that a business uh
and then how can we make that easily
consumable if you just press a button
and you magically get say pubnub for
example
that's like the best possible business
because it's like money in
easy oh no problem uh and it takes a
little bit more than that like with uh
with a
company like pubnub there um there's of
course
that freemium model right so it's like
give you the taste make sure that
it's what you're looking for and gets
you that aha moment
oh wait a second i didn't know that's
something that could be done
like that's that's like that's what one
of my challenges is trying to educate
the market saying
this is something that you can do and
especially now with you know a lot of
the work from home
we've seen a massive increase in in our
graph or
our traffic okay so since we started on
pub now what what is pubnub what service
are you providing and what is that aha
moment that you're referring to
that people already in the freemium
model are getting
uh yeah so this uh so we're a
communications platform that allows
uh multiplayer gaming or delivery
or peloton bike experiences where you're
shared in a classroom
and uh there's just so many things like
we have delivery services that use this
so it tracks the map uh the car on the
map as it's going by
like how how close is my chipotle order
i'm hungry i want it
i need it now so that's the kinds of
things that we we take care of and we do
it really
we're better than everyone else doing it
and uh we've got we're actually the
world record holders
actually in the largest online events
yes what what does that mean tell me
about these world record holder
holdings uh for the largest number of
concurrent
uh audience members in history in human
history
we hold uh for sporting events in a
subsidiary of disney
uh we we powered their television
televised event and
millions tens of millions of viewers
were all
connected with this shared experience
and power through power through our
network this sort of like
a nice little badge of honor that we
have stephen that we've achieved
you're sitting either at home if it's
coveted or in your office if it's
the regular life and in real time you
have tens of millions of people
that are getting their data getting
their their experience
through pubnub and it's a technology
that you're responsible for
you are the leader of it you are you're
you're holding the technology stack
right
is that scary is that fun
oh it's it's uh it's exciting there's
just so much
those but it's also a little like you're
saying scary
um yeah because we we actually power
uh we power airports and the feeling of
planes
and we make phones ring and
really important messages they go
through the system and we can't lose
them
like if we if we lose them some
catastrophe is awaiting
and if like some big like we have
and we have to keep the innovating right
we have to keep software moving so we
need to build a system
right that is able to be updated
while not dropping a single message
wow that's hard that's scary that's
challenging and
that's that's like that's what we're
that's what we're doing and that's what
we're really good at
you you mentioned the term educating the
market before
actually a lot of the things that you've
been referring to in this talk so far i
i feel like
i i think that i've you know been
learning through all these different
entrepreneurial courses at stanford
or venture capital courses or
entrepreneurial courses and andreessen
horowitz articles and you've condensed
it into your
pubmed journey which i think is just
inspiring what what is educating the
market to you and how did you need to
educate the market to get pubnub to
where it is today
so it's a it's the same it's the same
challenge with every company you know it
doesn't really matter if you have like a
very specific product
or sort of a horizontal communications
network like we have
the challenge is finding a way to
communicate with
a specific industry and use case right
so how i was describing
the car on the map right that's going
through you can see how close your
chipotle order is
you need you need to have those stories
you need to relay them
in a digital fashion in a way that's
consumable for your audience right your
target audience
right that's that's like the hardest
part and it also feels
it feels scary to do that because now
you're sick
you're like siloing your market and it's
like but we're only going to capture
this
level of revenue and then it's like what
what about all this other
sea of revenue over here you're leaving
it on on the table
actually no you're not because you
you're gonna laser focus and you're
going to nail
that target you're going to get those
customers so that aha moment you're
going to
be able to bring in more qualified leads
and then you can take that pattern this
is a cool part this part i love i love
this
you can repeat it you can repeat that
pattern and go after
all the rest of those industries and all
those markets and
and win at a much better rate and that's
that's critical you have to do that
verticalization so from what i
understand a lot of
the majority of people fail at that
laser-focused part right so they have
they may have a good product they may
have a good idea they have a good sense
of the market
but they failed to have that laser focus
and i'm thinking back to
a first-run article about superhuman
where they talk about how they how they
nailed down on their on their target
market and and really
were laser focused what was that
experience like for you how do you
become laser focused on a specific
sub-market of the sub-market
uh truck it's trial and error but also
it's there's there's a bigger there's a
bigger hurdle it's ourselves
it's ourselves because convincing
ourselves to do it
of course is is the biggest biggest
challenge and we're we're a big team
right
and a lot of folks are responsible for
getting those those keep those key
metrics
successful right we got to tart we have
targets and goals and we have to hit
those
and then if you just focus on one
particular area
[Music]
it's worrisome so trying to like get us
all on the same page to do that that's
been the
number one challenge i love the hardest
problem i love it
steven take me back 10 years you're
starting out uh
pubnub what was that like tell me they
told me that the
the founding story of provenance
uh so i was always been entrepreneurial
right my uh my my family my grandfather
they owned a local
a local business in in the city and they
sold
you know uh pipe fittings and uh and
other types of utility
utility uh systems that that uh
i don't know if that inspired me or
ingrained me
into just being oh this is the way it
needs to be
we just have a business and you go for
it and finding like an approach there's
always had that
always had that a desire uh wrote so
with pubnub just uh it was like
oh this is a new way here's a problem
making i need i want this phone over
here this
this phone like i want this phone to
talk to that thing over there and i want
it to be as easy as possible
how can i make that possible how can i
do that well i didn't know much about
networking i didn't know much about
yeah i was like i was like it was like
how could i make that
easy okay uh i need to learn about this
i need to learn about
linux kernel apis i need to learn about
networking pas what is an ethernet frame
what is
uh what does it look like on what's a
tcp tuple right
can we do udp what is that what is even
that right
so i had to figure all that stuff out i
didn't i didn't know i just and but i
wanted to be
i wanted it to be the best right i
wanted it to have like
all these technologies out there that
allowed you to do communication had
limitations
right like uh like the att network they
have
so much hardware because the software
has limited
i'm like i want i don't want that limit
i don't want
my when i make phone ring across the
world i don't want it to wait three
seconds
because it has to go through all these
switching boards i want it to do
as soon as you press your finger on the
phone the call button i want it to ring
on the other side
like that's that's what my goal was so
like having having that objective
for like high quality and efficient and
then just being able to sell it as well
without having any overhead that was
that was the goal it's like creating a
business that could do that
and get people really excited and then i
could take it and then show people how
cool it was
on every single possible use case that
was that was the vision that was a
driver
so i'm going back to the beginning
you're saying the technology for you
as the chief technology officer is a
means to an end what you're really
excited about is the impact that you're
able to make
whether it's connecting tens of millions
of people and a single
point in time or over the span of 10
years really educating the market and
becoming a market leader
and and and this multiplayer
communication
so back then when you're talking about
you know figuring out tcp udp
ethernet frames i mean that's
complicated stuff that's not the eddy
stuff that the average person would just
you know on their friday night sift
through wikipedia and you know um
research papers and learn about so there
has to be a deep technological curiosity
beyond
just the means to an end right
you would think really
uh maybe is it so like would i do this
for fun
just for the heck of it right like that
would be kind of like the question
uh maybe i mean i did i did some game
development back in the day and i
thought that was pretty cool
right getting into video games you're
breaking the whole conception of what i
think
of a chief technology officer stephen
this is this is very difficult for me
yeah yeah yeah it's uh i mean i think
even if no matter what your like
approach is
and your stance on technology and and in
your your field as well
i think it comes down to what's what's
mo what's driving you what
what's pushing you forward what's going
to make sure that you're
you're you're succeeding and you're
always at the forefront
it happens that technology has to be
there in order for you to accomplish it
if it was wizardry and magic i would
probably
i'd probably be doing that but it's this
is as close as we get
technology so andreessen wrote the
famous piece software is eating the
world you're evidently
a you know a key figure and improving
that software is eating the world i love
the analogy that you made
to att's you know hardware solution
versus a software solution
and obviously andreessen that's that's
what he touches on that the fact that
you can scale
at practically no cost and get
exponential
increase in usage for a relatively
linear increasing cost i mean that's
that's the name of the game
but but it must not be that smooth of a
journey over 10 years it can't all be
i'll be you know butterflies and
whistles right so so
what are talking about some of the
hurdles that you passed through and how
you overcame them
well yeah we're software and we make
we're human since we make mistakes but
we're really good at
realizing those mistakes okay and that's
probably like the best part of humanity
is like
i would say that's our strongest asset
right
is being able to recognize mistakes and
fixing them
uh and we're we're not available we've
made mistakes
some of our client sdks are connectors
to our network
we're running on att phones
and there was an upgrade that they made
which caused some sort of
incompatibility thing
and it it made the device connect and
disconnect
over and over and over and we had to
create new cipher
uh cipher keys every single connection
because we're
we want to make sure the connection's
secure and then it cost
and it was a slow rollout and they
didn't upgrade and
eventually all the phones all the 18t
phones in america
were doing this they were doing connect
disconnect over and over and we're like
what's going on we can't
we didn't have any logging at the at
layer 5 and we didn't know
we just we just saw that the the cpus
were going to the roof like what's going
on what's going on
it turned it turned out that we had a
faulty reconnect
logic inside of our sdk for the
particular sdk that
t was using on their phones and in order
to
to solve that we had to get all att's
ip block space that they owned for the
cell network
and then route them to a specific
destination so that way we can get the
rest of the traffic healthy
it was that happened this year
wow that was this year yeah and it was
it was very tragic and it was very
heartbreaking uh
and we we did we did hurt we did harm
some of our customer relationships but
we we were able to figure out what the
problem was and we solved it and
in the future if we run into this again
we have
we have the tools ready right i i i love
going back to what you said that as you
know humanity we're really good at is
identifying the mistakes we're making
and hopefully solving them and i don't
think that
you know all of humanity is good at
doing that i can think of a few key
examples
we're not necessarily good at doing that
but but but i love
the i love the fact that you are
taking the lessons and and being very
direct about it being very
intentional about the lessons that
you've learned there
owning that mistake and and improving
upon it and and i think that's that's
the responsibility of being a leader and
a market leader
in something as crucial as multiplayer
communication what were some of the most
enjoyable moments
of this 10-year journey as an
entrepreneur
that's uh working working with the
customers that still still
still is today being able to see them
like wow is it really that easy yeah
it's if i could make it easier
i would i would and i am working on that
right now making it easier faster better
stronger
that's we're not done yet but just
getting like some of our biggest
customers are
multiplayer games for mobile phones
they're they're
huge and they have the largest player
base and the most loyal player bases
right
and so we need to make sure they're
happy right because we want to keep
their revenues growing as well
our customers revenue and just just
being able to provide that and say this
is us we can do that for you
uh is is very satisfying right it's very
satisfying i don't know
right are there are there some lessons
that you learned as a technology leader
in the company because they're both
obviously you're you're you're leading
people but you're also leading
technology and and sometimes it feels
that there's this like
weird intermixing between the different
roles of the you know the ceo the cto
especially in record technology
companies how how do you look at your
role as a cto in terms of leadership
what's uh by example i would say
probably i mean i kind of like think of
it from that i mean if you're kind of
going down like because there's
different flavors of ctos if you ask and
this is this is actually common
questions like what do you what do you
do a cto those kinds of kinds of things
like
well really what what are you asking
really like what are you what are you
trying to get at
like usually these are other technology
folks who are asking me this question
that are in that role or about to go in
that role
and it's very different some are are vps
of engineering and they
operate the team uh and sort of manage
managers and and sort of help
structure that out and create like uh
you know trajectories
and career paths right right there's
there's that kind
uh there's also um innovators right so
at a larger companies you've got these
principal engineers or
ctos and they they look for
the frontier they're like what's new
what's what's amazing
what can we do to our company to make it
more secure
make it a billion dollars richer right
with
modern technologies how can we inject
those texts into and so there's
for me though i'm an entrepreneur like i
said it's a little different so i
i focus on what can we do what metrics
can we
monitor over the years and
for our teams to be able to be more
successful right and to know
that they're successful even before they
get like
a review right the annual review type
situation
how do we do that how do we make the
business scale how do we solve
training right because for for us though
it's really hard because
the language is different yeah every
single customer they come to us
like we need we need real time geography
map updates and now you've got a wholly
different than
multiplayer multiplayer connectivity and
i need to make sure that we have these
technologies and we can filter these and
we have this number
it's just a different conversation each
time so it's hard so that's kind of
things that we solve i love that stephen
i wish we could talk on for another hour
about this
it's just so fascinating but
unfortunately i for some weird reason i
called the show 20 milliliters instead
of
hour minute leaders so thank you for
being so generous with your time
i love to end with my favorite question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
ah wait that's like your whole hold on a
second
that's one that's a really hard one to
do you should have like
prepared me for that one so maybe you
did and i didn't read the email no no i
i apologize but but it is my favorite
question obviously i'm not holding it
accountable for those three words
off the top of your mind what words come
to you when you think of
who who what is the type of leader you
are how would your co-founder
you know think of of stephen blum
uh about realization
and overly excited i love that i'm
holding back i love that i'm holding
back right now
i love that stephen thank you so much
this was wonderful
really inspiring and and i love
following your journey thank you for
being a great supporter seven years ago
of my projects
i'm very very thankful for that and stay
safe and stay healthy throughout this
pandemic
yeah it's been great thank you thank you
for the time and
same to you thank you very much